We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I have a voicemail today from what could be
one of the wackiest, most uninformed conspiracy
theorists we've ever heard from.
Get the children out of the room and listen
to this.
And David, a nurse myself, I live in Florida
and my name is Vivian.
And I'd like to say that you are a fool, right?
Yes.
The elections were fraud.
Trump won by a landslide.
This was all a confiscation to steal the election
from some Trump.
Biden is a crook.
He is corrupt, so is his family and saw a
lot of members of the Democratic Party.
They sold this to the Chinese for the most
part.
They don't really give a rat's butt about
our country.
OK, so I am 100 percent agree with Trump.
I think that interview with Kilmeade was excellent.
And people like you and CNN and MSNBC and
NBC and all your stations, that everybody
basically report the lies, OK?
And they shouldn't even be called reporters
because you're all in the pocket of Soros,
Bill Gates and people like him.
All right.
It's disgusting what you're doing to this
country and the fools that listen to you,
that believe you.
It's really a darn shame.
You should be ashamed of yourself for calling
yourself an American.
People, like you said, we don't live in this
country, OK?
Don't change our country.
You've done enough time with your stupid ass
line.
So this is this is essentially this is proof
that we have a multi generational problem
in this country, OK, that doesn't get fixed.
You're not going to change that person's opinion.
Right.
Essentially, what you need to do is maybe
someday they'll learn something and maybe
their kids will be slightly more tethered
to reality if we improve circumstances and
maybe their kids like it's multigenerational
in that voicemail, she says.
Trump one.
Biden is a criminal.
Biden's family is criminal.
The Democrats sold us to China.
All news stations tell only lies.
I'm funded by George Soros.
I'm funded by Bill Gates.
It's it's a 90 second voicemail.
And there's about eight different baseless
conspiracy theories with anti-Semitic undertones,
of course.
And you know everything else.
You can't fix that by saying, hey, maybe we
regulate Fox News.
Or, you know what, like the.
Takeaway is.
The country is deeply sick.
And there's a lot of people that are very,
very sick and you can't fix that quickly.
It's sad.
It's very sad, but you just can't fix that
quickly.
Oh, we've got a great bonus show for you today.
I'll see
you then.